Volkswagon self disclosed that they had
an additional eight hundred thousand
vehicles that were affected by
irregularities now crucially this has to
do with carbon dioxide not nitrogen
oxides nitrogen oxides had been the
scandal that affected those 11 million
vehicles there could be some overlap on
the vehicles between the eleven million
that we knew about
and the 800,000 that they announced last
night what we see listening to the
companies talk to to dealers and to
suppliers there's no major change in the
way of also going to doing business and
sensitive note cutting production
schedule or ordering fewer parts etc
consumers are not running away from the
brands that you would expect it's a
beautiful brand in many ways for
consumers it's gonna be in between
premium and volume and you don't give up
on that brand people are like that car
is proud of that cars in many ways and
that's very best well this the most
important asset they have right now to
navigate this crisis and hopefully
convince customers that no the cars are
as good as people thought they were and
it's not that that dollar is not lost at
all polos calls Passats a couple of
Audis the a1 and the a3 hatchback then
the Skoda Octavia the C at Ibiza and the
C at Leon now as I mentioned it affects
both petrol and gasoline engines as well
as the diesel engines the only gasoline
engine it really affects is that 1.4
liter in terms of the diesels it's the
ones we know about the 1.4 the 1.6 and
the 2-liter TDI engines these have been
problematic this is what has been most
of the problem with the diesel aspect
aspect of this scandal
he's obviously worried about everything
that's going on within Volkswagen I
would be still and I said that last time
as well I would be surprised if the
board knew what's been going on it's a
different question whether they should
have known and we're going back to the
culture and the question we discussed
that nothing's been reported up the
questions haven't been asked on the
three liter diesel engine I think it's
it's really the devil is in the detail
these ACD devices when did they kick in
during the test when that they switch
off again and I think that's the reason
why they're denying any wrongdoing there
I think that it really comes down to
what is your time horizon for investing
you know one can be pretty confident I
think in 10 or 15 years that diesel as a
fuel in automotive is going to be a
whole lot less important than it is now
and that fuel usage is going to be a
whole lot less important because of
driverless cars engine management
systems and the like so when I think
about Warren Buffett's advice investing
if you ain't use us investing in 1900
the a car industry is invented what
would you do he said sell the horse